voilà le mali et ce redéploiement
évidemment dont il va être question cet
après midi à bruxelles un ce sixième
sommet union européenne union africaine
qui s'ouvre en 14 heures emmanuel macron
est d'ailleurs arrivée à bruxelles je ne
sais pas si on a on a l'image ce sera là
la deuxième séquence un plus plus
européenne qui va se tenir cet après
midi et ces deux prochains jours on va
retrouver sur place notre correspondante
à l'x le bourdon alix bonjour on était
censé se concentrer aujourd'hui sur la
situation en ukraine
finalement le mali risque bien
s'immiscer dans les discussions de jours
en effet un cette annonce va sans doute
occupé une grande partie des discussions
aujourd'hui et demain à l'heure de ce
sommet entre l'union africaine et
l'union européenne c'est un grand sommet
un qui s'ouvre puisque vous l'avez dit
40 des 55 dirigeants de l'union
africaine ont répondu présents et le but
affiché sur le papier est très ambitieux
puisqu'il s'agit de renouveler la
relation privilégiée de l'europe avec
l'africain mais évidemment évidemment
plein sur le début de ce sommet cette
annonce du retrait des forces françaises
et européennes du mali mais pour la
france 1 cette annonce en amont de ce
sommet aux côtés de dirigeants africains
et surtout aux côtés de charles michel
le président du conseil européen c'était
tellement est un moyen de
multilatéraliser cette annonce un ses
skis emmanuel macron essaie de faire
déjà depuis des mois européaniser un
cette question de la lutte anti
djihadistes au sahel en c'est d'ailleurs
là front ceint vous le savez qui avait
été à l'initiative de la de la task
force takouba cette coalition de forces
spéciales européennes dans le but est
bien d'impliquer justement davantage les
partenaires européens sur le terrain du
sel sur le terrain malien alors cette
task force elle a mis du temps ça a été
assez laborieux de la mettre en place
dix pays au bout du compte c'était
engagé
dans cette taskforce takouba mais
l'allemagne important qui avait été
sollicité plusieurs fois n'y a pas
participé puis il ya aussi des pays
comme la belgique et les pays bas qui
ont eu une participation tout à fait
minimaliste dans ce dispositif on
sentait déjà une certaine frilosité de
certains états membres à s'engager sur
le terrain malien mais l'union
européenne vous l'avez dit dit vouloir
rester présentes au sahel par le biais
de ses autres opérations justement alex
comment convaincre les européens aient
finalement de rester on a bien senti ces
derniers jours et ces quelques dernières
minutes avec la réaction allemande le
scepticisme s'exprimer
et a écouté ce matin le chef de la
diplomatie européenne a annoncé vouloir
envoyer une mission au mali pour
vérifier ainsi les conditions étaient
réunies pour le maintien des opérations
de l'union européenne alors on a parlé
de la task force takouba 7 coalisation
cette coalition pardon de forces
spéciales européennes créées il y a deux
ans il a été annoncé ce matin que des
militaires de tape de takouba seraient
redéployés au niger le niger ça semble
être un point d'appui assez naturel
puisque plusieurs pays européens ont
déjà des missions bilatérale dans ce
pays mais il ya aussi aux mamies un rôle
savez l'opération européenne de
formation eu une tm pour laquelle les
européens vont devoir se montrer très
prudent l'union européenne avait déjà
employé des précautions de langage
lorsqu'elle a maintenu cette mission
lors des deux coups d'état en 2020 et
2021 il faut aussi savoir que les
autorités de bamako au moins d'amertume
finalement vis-à-vis de l'union
européenne que vis-à-vis des autorités
françaises mais vous l'avez dit aussi
que c'est un certain scepticisme semble
monter parmi les partenaires européens
et dans et dans la foulée de l'annoncé
du retrait français 1 l'allemagne s'est
dite sceptique quant à la prolongation
justement de sa participation à le huer
m merci beaucoup alix l'abandon en
direct de deux banques